the labor leader so kirst armor will
address the British Chambers of Commerce
today as he attempts to woo business
Chiefs by setting out his vision for
reforming planning laws sakir is
expected to say that under his plans
councils need to have the final say on
whether homes can be built on Greenbelt
Land and I'll be pleased to say the
labor leader joins me now from the QE2
Center in central London Secour storm
away good morning to you before we talk
about your planning reform proposals I'd
just like to get your reaction to What
stilantis have said overnight they
effectively want the UK government to
renegotiate its brexit deal
well I do think that we need a better
deal than the one that we've got
um I do think there are other things
that we need to do as well supply side
chains
Etc need to be improved so there's a lot
of things but is the brexit deal we've
got working well no it isn't and we need
to improve on that and that's part of
our plan to make brexit work
so you will actually be looking to
renegotiate the brexit deal with the EU
yes we want a closer trading
relationship I think there's more work
we can do with the EU on science and
Innovation I also think there's more we
can do in the security space as well so
I think there are real improvements to
be made to the EU deal I don't think
many people look at that deal or think
it's working uh very well it was we're
promised to you know an oven ready deal
and um we got something which was
frankly Half Baked so there's a lot of
work to do there as there is on
everything else to improve on that clear
up the mess and then power our economy
forward because if there's one thing
that has been significantly bad over the
last 13 years or so it's our growth rate
our economy hasn't grown at the rate
that we need it to grow and that's why
I've said that an incoming labor
government if we're privileged enough to
be voted in will have as a central
Mission economic growth highest
sustained growth in the G7 and that
needs to be felt in living standards
Rising across the whole of the country
now the UK's trade performance has
deteriorated pretty badly since brexit
would you be open to going as far as
rejoining the EU single Market
no I don't think we should rejoin either
the EU generally or the single Market
but I do think that we should break down
barriers if you look at you know car
manufacturing is obviously in the news
today we've been a very good car
manufacturer for many many years we've
been good because the way that we've put
manufacturing together has been all of
the parts that are needed for the car
coming in as seamlessly as possible
arriving at the assembly point at just
the right time so that cars can then be
built turned around and out of the
warehouse as quickly as possible that's
a model of manufacturing that has worked
it has been impeded by the EU deal that
we've got and that's why we need to
improve on the deal I do think we can do
other things as well though I mean some
of those parts I think we should be
making in the UK so we're not constantly
bringing them on over borders so all of
this has to ladder up to a very strong
comprehensive plan to grow the economy
well let's talk about what you're
looking to do with the planning regime
as I understand it you are essentially
looking to loosen planning regulations
yes we want to build more houses
um you know as you will know many people
watching this will know the aspiration
the dream of owning your own home is
very real
um you know not least because for
working people it provides security that
they desperately need and that has been
killed effectively by the government
because whereas we had targets for house
building until the tail end of last year
those targets have been taken down uh
that means now the blockers are in
charge and house building will drop
probably to its lowest level since the
second world war so what I want to set
out today is what an incoming labor
government again if we're privileged
enough to be elected in will do about
that partly that's about putting those
targets back up but that on its own I
don't think will do enough we need to
get to grips with the planning framework
because at the moment it's those that
own the land and developers who
essentially choose how many houses and
where they're going to be I think we're
going to drive house building up at PACE
we need to put local areas in charge of
that so change the planning rules have
development corporations as vehicles on
the ground to drive building and make
sure that the the dream the aspiration
of owning your own home is realized for
so many people who at the moment have
had their dreams shattered and and you
know I I know when I was growing up my
dad was a tool maker working in Factory
my mom was a nurse we didn't have a lot
of money and sometimes we struggled with
our bills but we did have our own house
with a mortgage and that sense of
security so I never feared as a child
that we wouldn't have a roof over our
head our own roof over our head and
that's the sort of security that goes
alongside that aspiration to own your
own home now you've said in the recent
past you want to give communities more
say over developments in in their area
what if these communities don't want to
have their local Green Belt concreted
over
well on the
um basic principle the local area should
have a greater say I think that's really
important because at the moment as I say
land owners and developers tend to
choose warehouses are put and that often
leads to a conflict with local
communities whereas if local authorities
local areas had the had more of a say I
think it would actually reduce those
local conflicts you asked me about the
green belt of course we want to protect
our Countryside when we went on holiday
when I was a child we went to the Lake
District the countryside is rich is to
be protected but we are going to have to
make tough choices and there are parts
of the green belt where we build now and
I think there are better choices to be
made and the example I'd give just to
bring my argument alive if you like is
that there's been a housing development
in the southeast of England where the
choice for the Housing Development was a
playing field or a car park the car park
was technically in the green belt and so
protected
and so the playing field which was
technically outside the green belt was
chosen for the building so we've ended
up
um with a car park being protected and
the playing field being used to build
houses I just think that we've got to
make different choices so this is not
about disrespecting the need to protect
the green belt and the countryside of
course we've got to do that but got to
make tough choices about and if you let
local areas decide I'm pretty sure they
would say look if we had the choice we'd
have put those headers up on the car
park and save the playing field that's
that's common sense and it will drive
house building and that is also part of
our plan for rebuilding the economy
because for every hundred thousand
houses that we can build across the
United Kingdom then broadly speaking
that's one percent of GDP that goes up
that's desperately desperately needed
just at the moment
you're also talking about ending the
moratorium on onshore wind farms in
England what sort of veto will
communities have if they don't want
these things on their doorstep
well committed to have to have a say but
at the moment the system is tilted so
that if only a few people object it
takes years to get anything done and
um what we're saying about planning on
housing applies frankly equally to other
business sectors whether it's wind farms
the Laboratories we desperately need the
warehouses we need all of the planning
is taking far far too long I asked one
of the energy CEOs if we're in
government how long would it take you to
build a wind farm and he said to me
about two years I said well why then
does it take 13 years or so now before
anything actually happens and they said
well it's two years to build it's about
five years for the planning and then the
grid which needs to connect to the wind
farm doesn't really crawl towards the
wind farm until the wind farm is
finished and you end up with 13 years
that's far too long and businesses
across the country Express their
frustrations time and again that the
whole thing takes too long and that
helps holds us back because other
countries are much more streamlined
they've changed their rules
um and they're winning the race for the
next generation of jobs we have to take
the tough decisions to turn that around
so that you know when the question is
asked you know which nation is going to
lead on wind turbines which nation's
going to lead on hydrogen the answer is
why not Britain
now staying with energy the unite Union
which is your biggest financial backer
has called today for the
renationalization of the entire UK
energy industry is that something you're
going to consider
well we have considered it and
um decided that it isn't the right step
and I'll tell you for why we looked at
it the summer before last when Energy
prices as you know went through the roof
and there was this question well
wouldn't it be better then to bring them
into some sort of public ownership and I
looked at it with my team and I said
well how much would it cost us to do it
and then the crucial question if we did
it would that reduce the prices which is
obviously the thing that's pressing on
people at the moment and the answer that
is no because even if you nationalized
brought it into public ownership energy
companies still have to buy on the
global market and that's why we did
consider it and in the end rejected it
as not actually answering the central
question which is how do you drive down
those Energy prices and I think there
are better things that we did it in
France
Energy prices
well I think it depends on the
configuration as to whether it's linked
to the producers of the oil and gas or
Renewables in the first place but the
the other things I think we could do is
we can Rush towards Renewables we do
believe that there should be a publicly
owned vehicle for that so that as we go
towards Renewables we want GB energy a
publicly owned company to be the vehicle
for ensuring that the proceeds of that
come back to the British taxpayer and
are used you know to help bring those
bills down so I'm not ideologically
opposed to something that's in public
hands in fact we're proposing GB energy
but that's to yield the future work that
we want to do there are other things by
the way I'm very very keen on the idea
that we properly insulate our homes if
we've been doing that for the last five
six seven years then millions of homes
would have very cheap bills I've seen
this you've probably seen it yourself in
places like Yorkshire where you go to
one of the homes that's been stripped
out in insulated properly and I went
there the people living there were
beaming from ear to ear on a freezing
February morning because their house was
warm their bills were very very low and
that ought to be not just what we expect
of new houses but what we expect to be
retrofitted to existing houses because
in the long run what we do with energy
bills you know we need to keep them down
there's been price freezes in place
they're very expensive things to do but
we've got to do the fix the fundamentals
if you like at the same time okay Before
I Let You Go you've obviously been on a
great mission to rekindle relationships
with businesses every CEO I know has met
either you or Rachel Reeves over the
last year or so can you carry your party
with you on that because you've even
been talking to private Equity
Executives which are for a lot of your
uh party uh a sort of uh folk devil
almost
yeah we've spoken to no end of CEOs and
um and I've changed my party and my
party now is fully signed up to this we
know that to grow the economy we have to
partner with business and when I say
we're pro-business what I mean by that
is that we recognize that business is a
Force for good that the next generation
of jobs secure jobs and output for this
country is with a active Dynamic
government if you like sleeves rolled up
working alongside businesses and that's
why the discussions we've had with CEOs
has not been just a cup of coffee get to
know you it's also been about how do we
work together in government and that's
why Rachel and I have met so many CEOs
we went to Davos as you may have seen to
speak directly to investors and to ask
you know what's the inhibitor why aren't
you investing in the UK in the way that
we think you should and a large part of
their answer was because we haven't got
the stability we haven't got the
partnership that we need from the
government at the moment and I'm
determined that we'll turn that round
and just as I've turned around my party
we want to turn around the country so
that we can drive forward to what I'm
absolutely convinced would be a better
future
okay so care storm I appreciate you
joining me today thank you
just gonna break away from the business
news very momentarily you might have
seen the QR code on the side of your
screen the home Affairs committee is
right now examining the Metropolitan
police's approach to the coronation and
the handling of the protests over the
coronation weekend we're just going to
very briefly listen because if you view
protest as inherently problematic and
inconvenient rather than as a necessary
and important element of a free Society
bounce will almost always fall on the
side of maintaining order and preventing
crime whereas the starting position
should always be that peaceful protests
should not be restricted and should be
facilitated so far as possible and I I
agree with that and the evidence I
believe would show that that's what we
do getting the balance right between the
qualified rights of protesters and the
impact is is difficult but and protest
is by its nature designed to get
attention we understand that
um but I'm very clear that there was a
strong presumption in favor of the right
protest and that's important in a
Democratic Society but where that Strays
into crime then obviously the police
will inact deal with the laws as we find
them but this is something we are very
familiar with and we understand the sort
of Human Rights position Constable Noble
do you want to add anything on that yeah
just a couple of points well there you
go if you want to continue following the
home Affairs select committee you can do
so by scanning the QR code which is
going to pop up on your screen any
second now
there it is
now the global chemicals group ineos is
warning that the government's 75
windfall tax on oil and gas producers in
the North Sea will lead to a collapse in
investment in the Basin India also owns
the 40s pipeline system the largest
pipeline in the North Sea which annually
transports just under a third of the
UK's total oil production to the
mainland it's linked to more than 85
fields in the North Sea giving inios a
unique insight into the investment plans
of oil and gas producers it says that
investment is now going elsewhere I've
been speaking with Brian gilvary he's
the chairman of ineos energy
I think what we've seen over the last
two or three years we've come out of
covid so if you remember we went into
the covert period it was really hard in
terms of trying to maintain jobs through
that period we came out we saw a bit of
a bounce on demand particularly out of
China Capital was starting to be back
invested in the North Sea
um and then I think what we're now
beginning to see over the next year two
years people trying to maintain the
positions they have but we're not seeing
major new investment going in from the
big Independence uh and that you know
the independence of the big lifeblood of
the North Sea and we're simply not
seeing that at the moment but you're not
necessarily seeing investment draining
away either I think now what the
situation is if you look at the windfall
tax that was introduced in the United
Kingdom which came along for reasons to
alleviate the cost of energy and these
super high profits we were seeing being
published by the big integrated
companies a lot of those profits
actually came from Trading and
necessarily those trading profits don't
all sit within the UK regime so I think
the idea of an introduction of windfall
tax made sense at the time to alleviate
the cost of energy for domestic users
which seemed totally reasonable but that
windfall tax has now become it's been
increased by a further 10 so it's now at
75 percent compared to 40 where we were
oil prices were 120 a barrel back then
now they're 60 lower so if you look at
where the oil price is today we're 60
off those those highs and yet we still
have this windfall tax of 75 so it's
very simple economics and if I have a
pound do I put a pound into the United
Kingdom economy or do I translate that
to a dollar in print the United States
where the tax rate is around 37 to 40
percent for the offshore production
compared to 75 in the United Kingdom and
in the United States you've also got the
inflation reduction act which is
encouraging big green energy Investments
so you've now got this ability to invest
in the United States at the a stable
fiscal regime and this has always been
the issue with the United Kingdom
they're all see is that with the
stability see the fiscal regime is a
major problem
but also you can start to think about
things like carbon capture around the
inflation reduction act so I think right
now the UK is not a particularly
attractive place to invest from an
energy perspective in terms of oil and
gas the North Sea the government would
say well Hang on we're offering tax
releases for investment in the North Sea
that can be as much as 91 which I think
is right so so they they introduced that
as a sort of catch-all to try and
alleviate the impact but there are very
few companies spending the levels of
capital and it's really the big
integrated Majors that are spending that
level of capital that will alleviate
those taxes so effectively what that
means is the independence in the North
Sea are left then to effectively carry
that tax burden because of course if
you've got those big tax
um 91 incentives and your trading
profits are outside the ring fence
effectively I think those big integrated
companies will be paying the minimis low
levels of tax compared to what was
envisaged around the windfall tax which
is why presumably the likes of shell and
BP are still investing in the North Sea
Basin you'd have to ask them that
question
right what about Norway though I mean
Norway's tax rate is even higher than
the UK's it is and it's about 78 so it's
a very high number it's one of the
reasons why we exited as any of us
opposition in Norway and we took that
capital and invested it into Denmark
where again we have a more stable tax
regime
um so it's a choice for governments as
to how much tax take they wish to take
but there are consequences for those
choices and I fear a little bit coming
into this winter as we saw last year 60
of European gas or rather gas storage in
Europe and the United Kingdom 60 of that
gas came from Russia
that gas won't be available this winter
and it is very possible that we'll come
into this winter and find ourselves with
curtailed investment in our own
generation of oil and gas in the United
Kingdom that we're forced to import gas
again to deal with
um a cold winter which is possible this
year and that gas last year was being
imported 10 times the cost of the gas in
the United States which is extraordinary
you could buy Henry Hub gas at seven
dollars an mm BTU in the United States
and import it into Europe or the United
Kingdom at 70 and mmbtu it's a 10 to 1
ratio and so therefore I think what we
should be focused on in terms of the
United Kingdom is continuing to
encourage investment in our own energy
and infrastructure that we're going to
need for multi-decades ahead even as we
think about the energy transition and
the UK government itself has said how
important oil and gas will be out in
2050 in terms of balancing the needs
from a power perspective isn't the
security of Supply argument slightly
diminished though by the fact that a lot
of North Sea output is actually exported
no today actually a lot of that gas
comes on Shore if you looked at last
year we had to import if you look at the
levels of LNG in last winter when we
suddenly because the issue is a lot of
our gas comes in from Europe we import
from Europe through the through via the
interconnectors
as Europe started to back off and hold
its storage we started to see more LNG
now what the United Kingdom did really
well uh over a decade ago was to build a
big infrastructure of LNG import
terminals to enable us to bring gas in
but that gas comes in at a very very
high premium and the issue that we have
fundamentally in the UK is we have
nothing like the amount of gas storage
in the UK compared to Europe It's
relatively de minimis things like rough
which was important part of
infrastructure that we still are talking
about whether roof comes back into play
a really important bit of critical
infrastructure as is 40s pipeline that
ineos runs and of course we have to
invest in that pipeline to ensure that
the oil and gas is available to us in
the future and therefore we need to make
sure that companies are continuing to
invest in the future of the North Sea to
enable that key piece of infrastructure
to continue to operate I think you're
about a third of the way through the the
major investment projects that you've
planned for 40s is that in danger might
this project never be seen through to
completion I think it will be in danger
if we don't see investment in the North
Sea infrastructure that will generate
the more oil and gas that we're going to
need to see flow through that Pipeline
and flow into the United Kingdom and it
seems baffling to me that we would have
a integrated energy strategy that relies
on imports from the United States or
Qatar or other locations around the
world rather than relying on our own key
infrastructure that we have available to
us at much much lower cost
no the labor party circus Dharma has
said he wants to see what he calls
proper windfall taxes he doesn't think
uh the industry is paying enough as it
is I think
um rhetoric when you are out of power
when you come into power you then start
to have to look at the policies
associated with those and the other
jurisdictions around the world as
governments have talked about what they
would or wouldn't do when they come into
Administration the Biden Administration
is a great example of the things that he
talked about what he would do when he
was out of power when he came into Power
actually it was a very different story
in terms of what happened the onshore I
can't comment on what a potential future
leader of this country should or
shouldn't do what I would say though is
if you don't invest and encourage
investment in your own infrastructure
you'll pay a much higher price if you
have to you have to import that energy
still to come on inking life we're going
to show you how the markets are doing
this Wednesday morning stay with us
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
arrested we aim to be the best and most
trusted place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skys
reporter based in Delhi
foreign
[Music]
has emerged from recession during the
first three months of the year meant
that yet again the Nikkei in Tokyo was
the star performer among Equity markets
in the Asia Pacific region overnight the
index closed above 30 000 for the first
time since September 2021. well in
Europe stocks have been trading largely
to the downside this morning here's the
current picture it's a busy day for
company results you can see the Dax
there is the only main Continental
European index up today and that's
because its two biggest constituents are
both trading higher the engineering
giant Siemens is there by two and a half
percent in Frankfurt as it raised its
four years sales and profits guidance
while the software group sap which is
Germany's largest company is ahead by
one and a half percent as its results
were also well received well here in
London the ftse 100 is just about in
positive territory it's more or less
unchanged right now mixed trading this
morning the London Stock Exchange itself
is the biggest Faller on the ftse 100
this morning the shares are down by some
five percent after private Equity Firm
Blackstone sold down at stake meanwhile
the credit rating group experience it's
off by just under four percent after its
annual gross prospects forecast came in
shy of expectations among the ftse
gainers this morning will Sage is
leading the way up four percent on its
results I'll be speaking to the CEO
shortly outside the ftse Morgan Advanced
Materials is ahead by nearly one percent
after getting a push from one of the
Brokers well on the downside the
industrial threads provide a coats group
is off by just over four and a half
percent as its results fell short of
expectations on the foreign exchange
markets well there's been a bit of
buying of the US dollar uh this morning
with a safe haven buying there in fact
Sterling off nearly half of one percent
against the Greenback the pound also
down by uh an eighth of one percent
nearly against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile is off by a third of
one percent right now against the dollar
as for the oil price well that was is
weaker this morning after an unexpected
rise in U.S crude inventories overnight
about a Brent crude will currently set
you back 74.78
it's about that's offer six of one
percent will joining me this morning is
the head of investment at interactive
investor Victoria scholar Victoria good
to see a really busy day for company
News British land not terribly
encouraging no um this is a stock that's
down about 10 year to date and about 30
over the last year and it said that it
had a declining property valuations you
know it's heavily exposed to retail and
campuses as well we know there's the
demise of the High Street but more
broadly commercial real estate has been
struggling with that shift towards more
working from home but it did say that
the yield environment has been improving
you know we're heading towards the
potential peak of the rate hiking cycle
and it's interesting if you compare
British land to some of the house
builders like persimmon because they've
been reflecting this potential interest
rate Peak a lot better we've seen these
stocks they're much better in recent
weeks whereas British land is still
struggling a bit yeah I mean it was
interesting we had land Securities on
the program yesterday and there were
making the point yeah that there's
sentiment in the sector is awful there's
not a lot of investment going on and yet
they're still seeing good rental growth
decent occupancy levels so it's a really
kind of mixed market yeah I think it
really is you know on the one hand
um in the um sort of the the retail side
um we are seeing those rents pretty high
but um in terms of underlying valuations
they have been struggling so like you
say it's a bit of a mixed picture
another company that's caught your eye
this morning that's also reporting today
Mitchells and Butler's the pub operator
yeah so reported its half your earnings
and it's all adjusted earnings of 100
million pounds so falling from 120
million pounds last year but it did see
sales growth and it had some strong
sales over the Easter bank holiday
weekend but this is a stock that was
heavily punished last year with those
losses accelerating around the time of
the mini budget so we have seen the
stock start to regain strength off those
October lows so price action has been
quite positive but of course it's still
grappling with a lot of those
inflationary pressures around wages and
around energy and around food and drinks
prices too it is interesting though
there's a lot of positive sentiment in
the sector right now I mean JD
Witherspoon's numbers recently were very
very good Marston's yesterday seemed
quite sure people we had green King on
the other day Nick McKenzie the CEO
they're all fairly upbeat right now yeah
well you know I think beer is actually a
pretty resilient part of the market and
we've also seen that people are still
trying to enjoy those little luxuries
while they can amid the cost of living
crisis and that pressure on the
consumers so while they might not be out
there buying new cars or buying
electricals they are potentially still
going to the pub and having some sort of
enjoyment there yeah we can all drink to
that Victoria good to see you this
morning thank you
still to come here on Ian King live I've
been catching up with the chief
executive of JD Sports the company says
it's gonna it's the annual profit says
you have a billion pounds for the first
time stay with us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now last week saw the
competition and markets Authority give
unconditional clearance to the Takeover
of inmosats the global mobile satellite
Communications Provider by the U.S
company ViaSat it means that today's
earnings update from imarsata Supply to
Airline shipping groups and governments
around the world is likely to be its
last as a separate business or today the
company reported underlying earnings of
259 million dollars for the first three
months of the year that was up 32
percent on the same period last year
joining me now is in Moss that's chief
executive Rajiv Suri Rajiv good to see
you again
um Aviation really shot the lights out
for you this quarter up 32 is that As
Good As It Gets
it was uh it was phenomenal actually
good morning here and thanks for having
me uh yeah the in-flight connectivity
Services I.E Wi-Fi to commercial
airlines uh That Grew 75 percent year on
year overall the aviation business was
up 36 the other two segments also grew
just short of uh 30 percent uh the thing
here is that we've got strong order
backlog meaning that we've got orders
and we have to connect user terminals
onto aircraft so this bodes well for for
the long term for our Aviation business
so very pleased with the results and the
continued momentum there now your
Maritime business clearly suffered
during covid it feels now so it's back
to sustainable growth again is it would
that be the case it's definitely back to
sustainable growth um you know the
business is now growing six percent per
quarter it's a ninth consecutive quarter
of growth uh again here we've got strong
order backlogs so the vessels that we're
connecting with our high-speed Broadband
is you know it's 14 up so that again
boards well for for the future and I
think pleasingly the new high-speed
Broadband business is now greater than
the Legacy business so it's 60 40 and
that 60 is going fast so it is
definitely on a sustainable growth
trajectory now the US government in
particular seems to be spending
increasing sums with you I think
something like two and a half billion
dollars worth of new contracts last year
alone is the mix of of services and
solutions it's buying from you changing
greatly
more managed Services uh you know more
customized Solutions uh but so meaning
more airtime more managed services that
we use our commercial satellite
offerings to tailor them for government
and Military applications so we have
very strong underpin of contracts in the
US government but increasingly we're
also getting strong underpin of
long-term contracts in the non-us
government business fact our non-us
government business group 26 percent
year in year uh this quarter and this is
now the the third year of record results
for our you know non-us government
business
now since we last spoke you've joined
something called the space safety
Coalition what is that
uh it's very much about I mean in myself
started with saving lives at Sea with
saving lives in the air we saved about
six lives every day I'd see we're big
Believers and certainty and safety and
connectivity where it matters all of the
time but we're also big Believers in
solving the issue of space
sustainability you know we had 2 500
satellites in 2019 uh you know up in
space we now have 7 000 satellites at
the end of uh last year we're projecting
as an industry this will get to 100 000
or more satellites so imagine a hundred
thousand or more satellites most of them
in the low earth orbit so that that
really means there's Collision risk
there's a light pollution risk there's
uh risk to astronomical discoveries
there's uh there's black carbon being
deposited in the earth's upper
atmosphere with all the burning of uh
you know Illumina that takes place up
there so we're very worried about space
sustainability we're asking for a code
of conduct for the industry and also
regulation that that helps solve this
problem because we don't want space
debris with about a million objects up
there flying at 10 kilometers per second
which is six times the speed of a bullet
all it takes is a speck of paint to
collide with a satellite creating a
potential series of collisions so I
think both safety and space
sustainability is very close to our arm
okay Rajiv there's loads more I wanted
to ask you but we're really tight on
time today do appreciate you joining me
today sir thank you thank you
JD Sports said this morning it expects
its annual profits to top 1 billion
pounds for the first time this year the
sports fashion retailer made the
prediction as it reported a pre-tax
profit before adjustments of 991.4
million pounds for the year to the 29th
of January that was up four and a half
percent on the same period 12 years
earlier it partly reflected the impact
of new store openings mainly in the
United States but also in European
markets such as Hungary Lithuania and
Greece I've been speaking with JD's
chief executive Regis Schultz
yeah I think we are delivering fantastic
results this year I think that you know
we reached a 10 billion Mark which is a
key mark for us we almost reach 1
billion we just stop just below to have
something to celebrate next year so so
we are growing our number one market now
is U.S uh we are very balanced between
the different geography with 30 of
ourselves in North America 30 in Europe
30 in UK 10 in Asia Pacific we are
gaining share everywhere we operate so
you know it's uh it has been a fantastic
time and I think that it's a great
business we have invented something
which is unique which is a combin which
is at the middle between fashion and
Sport and all our products are sport
inspired but uh where every day they are
not designed to be to do Sports they are
designed to be to be an everyday and I
think if I can give an image is a
sneaker you go to a in the street and 80
and you know 10 years ago this would
have been 80 formulas and and that is
driving our growth and I think we have a
fantastic people I think that we should
always say that you know it's the
experience in our stores the energy uh
and and the service that you get is is
unique and uh and that is uh that is the
idea the United States has traditionally
been a bit of a graveyard for UK
retailers most notably Tesco before that
marks and Spencer what do you think
you're getting right over there that
some of the other UK companies that have
tried and failed over there didn't first
we we moved to the US by acquisition so
which has not been the case for Tesco or
for MLS so we have 1 000 store in the US
so and it's very local business so we
acquire business which are entrepreneur
business we keep the entrepreneur and
they continue to do what they do well so
that's the first things at the same
moment we use this base and strong base
to develop JD and I think that's that's
what makes us successful we have not
come and to say this is it you need to
uh we just come by business uh we we
take the team and we say you know what
we have this proposition how you think
it can work in the US and so they have
taken it they embrace it and they are
develop it and that's what makes us
unique they can you know we we haven't
we have 150 stores in the US so it is
working so it's not like you know
unproven we we just now delivering the
proposition but we have test enough we
have an economic model that works we
have a love index which is the is we we
we have a higher love rates and then our
key competitors in the U.S market so I
think that it's it's a great story
you're targeting I think 1750 new stores
within the next three years are you
trying to do much too quickly no are we
just responding to the customer you know
our customer is asking for having more
store so we we're just following our
customer you know we there is only three
countries in the world where we have a
double-digit market share UK Ireland
Australia and uh and in U.S or in Europe
we are around five percent market share
so we are big enough in order to say we
have some things that can be leveraged
at the same moment where we are not
responding to the customer need at all
so you know our love index is the same
across the world and but we have much
more reach to the consumer in UK than we
have in the rest so you know it's it's
great and I think you have seen that you
know in retail is go fast you know you
you see Lulu Lemon they are opening this
type of numbers so everywhere and no
problem at all so I think that we are in
the same same case we we have the we are
the love brand we are the trendy one we
are creating something new and customer
lovers and they want more from us if
said today that you raise prices by
between five and ten percent over the
year just finished what sort of price
increases are you anticipating this year
I think we should be back to a normal
inflation which is two to three percent
that's that's what we are looking at you
know it's a key factor of why uh price
has been increased has been energy and
transportation energy are back to uh to
normal I would say and transportation
costs are really back to normal so I
think that will will come back to to a
normal inflation and you know I will
always say that you know it's the most
important things for us is unemployment
and is the fact that the young people
can find a job you know it's great to
see that you know three years ago it was
impossible to find a job now today we
are all fighting to get the young adult
in our business and I think it's it's a
great situation and I think we should
celebrate more the low unemployment and
and look at the at the nice things that
is happening compared to inflation yes
inflation has been I and and 2i but it
has has been more dictated by short-term
unbalance of of the offer and the demand
and that is starting to come back but
you put your finger on a key point there
which is that consumer spending has been
under a great deal of pressure certainly
here in the UK you don't appear to be
suffering from that because a young
adult doesn't doesn't have a mortgage
doesn't pay the energy bill and the
parents are paying and so and they get a
job you know and you know yes my pair of
trainer cost perhaps five pound more
than it was costing last year but last
year they didn't or two years ago they
didn't have a job now they have a job so
the difference is much higher than the
five phones that they have to spend more
for for the Air Force and and the uh and
the gazelle
now if you own or run a small business
here in the UK there's roughly an even
money chance that you'll be a customer
of sage the newcastle-based companies
accounting human resources and payroll
software is used by more than three
million customers worldwide including
nearly half of the UK's smes so today
Sage announced underlying operating
profits of 227 million pounds for the
six months to the end of March that was
up 14 on the same period a year ago
joining me now is the chief executive
Steve here Steve good to see you this
morning Oliver
finding life quite tough at the moment
due to higher interest rates that
doesn't appear to be hitting your
renewal rates
yeah morning Ian I think um uh you know
generally small mid-sized businesses
obviously they've got some headwinds
they've got some increased costs
um but they're also on average you know
we've just done a survey over 80 percent
of the 12 000 smes that we surveyed are
feeling positive about the future and
over half of them are looking to invest
more in technology so what they're doing
is looking at how can they run their own
businesses more effectively more
efficiently and part of how they do that
is by investing in more technology
extent of you put up prices during the
last six months
yeah we what we've done is we've put up
prices sort of between about four or
five percent so we've sort of sought to
compensate
um for the salary increases we've given
our own people you know about 60 70
percent of our costs is people related
so we try to sort of focus on a fair
value exchange for our customers and not
certainly not put up prices in line with
inflation
people know you best for your accounting
software but what does that account for
of the overall sales mix these days
yeah well we tend to bundle things
together now so we you know we sell
people both accounting payroll HR but
the sort of core financials is still at
the heart of what we do so it's well
over half of our Revenue still comes
from those core Financial systems
whether you're a small business or a
mid-sized business it's that they it's
at the heart of the heart of what we do
now the generative AI is obviously the
Hot Topic of the moment to what extent
are you trying to incorporate that into
what you do
yeah we've always had AI over the last
few years always had AI embedded into
our products but you're right this this
next phase of generative AI is it's very
exciting it offers a number of
possibilities for small mid-sized
businesses in terms of aiding their own
productivity
um we have a major uh partner Summit
next week in the us and we're going to
be announcing some of the first products
which incorporate that generative AI
technology so we we see this as a very
positive thing for our customers now you
mentioned the U.S 40 of your sales now
come from the US compared with just 25
here from the UK would moving your main
listing to New York be make any sense
for you
well I think as you know we're very
proud of the fact that we were born here
in the UK born in the Northeast in
Newcastle and uh you know we we've not
seen any constraints to our growth
um as we seek to access Capital as we uh
you know seek to expand our business
we're very proud to be listed here in
the UK now well that's a music to the
years of a lot of people in the
Northeast in particular I suspect Steve
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live I'm
going to be speaking to the chief
investment officer at gxo Logistics
about the changing Trends in Supply
Chains Don't Go Away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
any given day would have been bustling
with people but today it's absolutely
deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
welcome back now during this
inflationary environment companies are
working harder than ever to keep their
costs down particularly when they're
selling direct to customers well that's
particularly the case in terms of
distribution costs which in turn means
that logistics companies are fighting to
reduce their own costs through
initiatives such as automation well gxo
Logistics is one of the world's biggest
managers of outsourced Supply chains and
warehousing with customers including
Sainsbury's Majestic wine and Ted Baker
for joining me now is its Chief
investment officer Mark manduka Mark
good to see this morning how does
Automation in the UK and Europe compare
with what you're doing in the US it's
actually very similar we're seeing a
huge investment in Automation and as you
said this is a drive towards
productivity for a number of our Global
Blue Chip customers so we're across 27
countries we run about a thousand
warehouses and we do it for a thousand
two hundred Global Blue Chip customers
and what we're trying to do is make
customers the best version of themselves
in the warehouse efficient
fast in the warehouse and also accurate
and automation achieves those goals now
obviously during the pandemic the the
just in time model for distribution was
tested almost to destruction is that
being replaced Now by sort of just in
case type attitude it was you saw that
in Q2 last year there was that shift
from just in time to just in case and
what we saw was a Changing of the Guard
historically what's happened in the last
30 years is there's been this outshoring
to Asia and everything being
manufactured and to some degree also
warehoused there the change that's
taking place now is that you're seeing a
lot of that come back onshore near short
and people want their inventory closer
to their end consumer and we're part of
that Journey as people move away from
China and come back to both the UK and
the us we're going to help them
warehouse and become more automated in
the process that sounds like you're
going to be needing more land in this
country and elsewhere there's going to
be a lot of growth I think from a
warehousing standpoint there's very
strong demand particularly as you go out
of London towards the M1 what you're
looking for is warehousing that's close
to major accommodations so when the
order comes through say for example with
e-commerce you're looking to make sure
that you're close to that end customer
so that you can deliver as efficiently
as possible but we operate within the
warehouse now you've just signed a big
contract with Sainsbury's I think it's
your biggest contract ever in fact what
sort of things are going to be doing
with them it's very exciting so we have
a 2.3 billion dollar pipeline so we're
signing with a lot of global Blue Chip
customers what we're looking to do with
every customer is make sure that their
inventory is Right sized for purpose a
lot of companies come to us and there
aren't very they aren't very automated
in their own sense so what we're looking
to do is automate them from an inventory
standpoint we're then looking to see
what we can do in terms of the variable
cost within the warehouse to make them
the most efficient version of themselves
and what inevitably happens when you
automate a warehouse is you see the
revenue throughput go up and in some
cases you see the accuracy of orders go
from roughly 95 on an unautomated
Warehouse so roughly 99.9 on an
automated one so big changes for
customers how big is the addressable
Market I mean the price people out there
that haven't outsourced what they do in
this front 500 billion dollar total
addressable market across North America
and Europe so there's a huge landmass to
play with for a company like mine that's
roughly doing 10 billion of Revenue huge
opportunity to take a lot of market
share I think over the next 10 years and
we're very much at the Nexus of
automation e-commerce Outsourcing and
also the nearshoring theme that you
mentioned now this time last year you
were in the process of wrapping up the
Takeover of clipper Logistics 965
million pound deal how has the
integration gone it's a fantastic
business so they run a lot of
multi-tenanted warehouses particularly
in the UK Market where they had a very
dominant Force particularly with those
multi-tenanted customers they were
running the best Global blue chip brands
so we're very pleased to have them on
board we've been enacting our cost
Synergy program with them that's been
going extremely well but more
importantly we're excited about the
revenue synergies that we can grow
multi-tenanted customers going to
Dedicated customers that's the muscle
that we're going to flex in that
business it's an exciting time and
briefly Mark you worked here in the city
as an analyst for 10 years what made you
want to go into business so I think the
reality is is that every sell side
analyst has their time I loved what I
was doing I was covering covering the
transportation space and I was covering
a lot of logistics companies to roll my
sleeves up and get my hands dirty on a
business That's so exciting and has so
much growth as you say from a total
addressable Market standpoint is a big
change and it's a great outlook for me
all right hope to see you again in
future thanks for joining me today
that's it from me for today there's much
more on the Sky News Mobile app and on
the website with reporting video content
and Analysis from our business team
we're back at tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock hope very much to see you then
in the meantime do stay tuned because up
after this short break it's Kimberly
Leonard with all the build up to prime
minister's questions and of course the
latest from that home Affairs select
committee meeting into the policing of
the king's coronation I'll see you
tomorrow thanks for joining me today
Julio
thank you